Did you know that friends
and family recommendations
are by far the best way to get
more users for your mobile app?
All you need to do is to make
it super easy for, say, Uncle
Joe to recommend your
app to his friends,
and then ensure that
his recommendation can
convert to an actual app install
with just a couple of clicks.
And the best part is, you don't
have to call it from scratch.
App Invites from Google can
take care of it for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I'm Jarek Wilkiewicz.
In this series,
I'm covering things
every developer
needs to understand
to be successful-- user
acquisition, engagement,
and earning money.
In this episode, we will
focus on user acquisition
and touch upon user engagement.
In late 2014, Ipsos
conducted a study
to investigate app discovery,
acquisition, usage,
and abandonment.
8,470 respondents, aged 18 to
64, participated in the study.
And when asked about how
they became aware of an app,
52% identified their friends,
family, and colleagues
as the most trusted source.
The same study found
the number one way
to get the user to install
or use an abandoned app
again are discount
coupons or credits
towards next purchase, new
content, friends or family
recommendations,
and new features.
All right.
So what does this mean
to you as a developer?
Well, you could try building
an app-sharing functionality
and post-install onboarding
hooks into your own app
from scratch.
Or you can integrate
App Invites from Google,
which is free,
enables app sharing
using SMS or over email, and
supports personalized user
onboarding for Android and iOS.
Let's take a look at an example.
I used to be a party man,
but that was before the kids.
Now when my wife and I want to
go out, we need a babysitter.
The Urban Sitter app
lets me find one.
As you can see in the
demo, Urban Sitter
knows that I'm likely to
be quite happy with the app
when I find a babysitter,
so it offers a button
to share the app with
my friends at checkout.
The button launches
an App Invites widget,
which automatically suggests
people I'm close to.
I can send the invitation
using email or SMS.
When it arrives in
my friend's inbox,
the invitation is personalized,
comes from a trusted source--
me-- and it contains
a discount offer.
Remember, discount offer
increases conversions.
Urban Sitter takes
advantage of that.
Upon installation, the recipient
can't resist a discount offer
and signs up for the service.
Thanks to Urban Sitter and
App Invites from Google,
my friends can also go out
and enjoy a good party.
Let's look at another example.
Remember Uncle Joe?
Turns out he's a
big fan of seafood,
and so am I. When Uncle
Joe finds a cool paella
recipe with Yummly, a recipe
app, he can share it with me.
Yummly uses App Invites
for content sharing,
and the first email
or SMS from Uncle Joe
will trigger a quick
install process for me.
Next time, when Uncle Joe shares
a yummy seared scallops recipe
with me, the email
or SMS from him
will trigger a
deep link directly
into the Yummly app on my phone.
As you can tell, even if I'm
not a frequent Yummly user,
the personalized recommendations
I receive from Uncle Joe
will make me use
the app more often.
This way, App Invites helps
Yummly with user engagement,
and you can do the
same for your app.
Let's look at some of the
technical details now.
You can get App Invites
from Google Play services
or CocoaPods.
The best way to start
is to try the sample app
for your platform.
Let's take a quick look.
In order to enable App
Invites for your own app,
go to g.co/AppInvites and follow
the instructions to set up
your project.
To share app content
deep links, App Invites
provides a widget
out of the box,
so you don't have
to code that part.
The invite email can be
tailored by your application.
For example, you can
use a custom image
and change the invite text.
If you integrate App Invites
into both your Android and iOS
app, your users will be
able to share app content
cross-platform.
For example, your Android users
could send the app content
to their iOS friends, who are
then guided through the app
install process in
order to view it.
OK, we've covered
sending invites.
Let's now talk about
the receiving side.
Once the user clicks on the
link delivered via SMS or email,
if the app is not
installed, the user
is taken to the
appropriate store.
Because App Invites is deeply
integrated with Google Play
services, on Android
this process is seamless,
and it doesn't require
browser redirects.
Upon installation, the app can
detect the referred deep link
using the App Invites
API and act accordingly.
For example, the deep link
can contain discount coupon
information to make sure
the new user actually
engages with the app.
In the Urban Sitter
example, the deep link
contains the discount code.
App Invites are pre-integrated
with Google Analytics.
So events such as
sharing and install
are tracked automatically
and visualized
in a handy dashboard.
You can also report conversions
in your own code using
the provided API to track key
events, such as the user making
babysitter reservation
after receiving the invite.
Monitor conversions in the
provided Google Analytics
dashboard and slice or dice
the data any way you please.
Pretty cool, huh?
And that's all there is to it.
To learn more, go
to g.co/AppInvites.
Your uncle is waiting.